[Music]
Deloitte what are you doing in my super
secret volcano office father's work ad
we're gonna be in San Diego and I
thought I could conquer it
excellent warlord instinct son Thunder
number one bring me my conquering flags
to plant on this San Diego oh come I con
no no more flags we could do some
father-son sightseeing oh oh happy fun
to conquer no don't oh that - that's not
what - la la
can you imagine how beautiful this city
would look at him smashed by my giant
mech
please just stop go I'm totally gonna
conquer this place it's at the top of my
bucket list don't worry he is not going
to destroy San Diego yet today but
someday
[Music]
you ready for Mina continent Jocko
I'll be waiting
dad sorry what was that last thing you
said what that last part I didn't catch
it well is anything what do you mean I
didn't what I said I'll be waiting and
then I stopped talking dad
no Lloyd that's right your son and it's
Lloyd no ll o yd I named you you ruined
my life that's not true I haven't even
been a part of your life how could I
ruin it wasn't even there baby now we
got bad
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm kicking ass animals to form the
secret ninja force are you ready to risk
your life on Ninjago yes I am maybe I
know you want me to save myself so
[Music]
hello who is this Lloyd Garmadon your
son hmm
[Music]
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect I mean my mom is weird
and collect seashells your dad levels
cities and attacks innocent people so
they've all got that quarks you know
[Music]